welcome back the community helps a
former strip entertainer get mobile
again
after he claims he was scammed online
when he tried to upgrade his motorized
scooter
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
joins us live in the newsroom tonight
with more on the effort
kristin sasha stride relies on his
motorized scooter it gives him
independence following his stroke 14
years ago
which left him disabled and unable to
speak he wanted an upgrade but
unknowingly made a bad deal and now the
community is helping stripe get around
again
his speech pathologist started a
gofundme three weeks ago
it's nearing the goal of 52-hundred
dollars to assist strive buying a new
scooter
after he traded his other one and paid
800 dollars
for this unit using facebook marketplace
he says it stopped working
after a few miles and a repairman cannot
guarantee
fixing the problem which may cost
several hundreds of dollars
stripe tells me he attempted contacting
the seller again with no luck but he's
grateful for the community support at
this time
i know it's friends from all over the
years that he has
they're just very supportive and want to
get him back on his feet what would it
mean
to have a new scooter
well my life
stride used to be a musician and a
comedian performing on the strip in the
1980s
despite certain setbacks from the
strokes he continues to try and live
independently
by using a scooter to grocery shop visit
friends and
attend his speech therapy appointments
stribe says his caretaker has graciously
driven him to therapy the last three
weeks
and helped him with other errands he
warns others to stay
cautious about making deals with
strangers online
reporting live in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now
just a beautiful story there kristen
we'll still